[Music]
if I ask you if there's any thread
stronger than a steel thread you would
definitely say no but there is an
artificial thread used in fabrics that
is stronger than a steel thread wait a
second
how can a fabric thread be stronger than
a steel thread let's find out
a miraculous fiber known by the name
nylon is what we are referring to yes it
is the fiber that is used in several
applications right from making clothes
to making durable ropes for trekking and
has always been in great demand nylon is
the first ever fiber that is completely
synthetic unlike rayon that uses
cellulose as starting material nylon
employs cold water and air but how
exactly did nylon come into existence it
was after World War one that an American
company started research for making
various fabrics that was strong elastic
and durable a Howard professor named
Wallace carrithers along with his team
was successful in inventing a polymer
that was highly elastic very strong and
at the same time extremely durable this
was synthesized using basic components
like cold water and air so can you guess
what this fiber could be yes it was
nylon however there were several
modifications made later to this piece
of work nylon was just the first
synthetic fiber produced as it did not
use any natural raw material like plant
or animal parts can you guess what the
first application of nylon was it was
used for making toothbrush bristles
however later it was widely used for
making ropes used for climbing mountains
and also in making parachutes as years
passed by there were several
modifications made in nylon what did
this lead to it helped increase its
applications so nylon was also employed
for clothing its appearance along with
the transparent nature was useful in
making
several varieties of clothes characters
like lightweight shiny appearance along
with the East to handle and wash the
fabric made it a choice of garment
makers and now we find nylon being used
to make almost every item that we use
daily blending nylon with many other
types of fabrics can help us obtain
materials that can have wide
applications no wonder why nylon
continues to be the choice of many since
ages
however nylon is not used to make warm
clothes yes
warm clothes are required not only for a
particular season but also throughout
the year in many parts of the globe
so what then we have wool that can
provide us fabric to be woven into warm
clothes however along with being
expensive it is also not available
easily so shouldn't we study a synthetic
fiber that will suffice the need yes so
do watch our next video shouldn't know
more
[Music]